this is a joint work with character
obsidian and i'm going to tell you today
about mechanism design with more
builders
many of the works in growth make
mechanism design
look for truthful mechanisms
these are mechanisms in which we
incentivize the bidders to report the
two valuations
the underlying assumption here is that
if we don't incentivize the bidders to
report the two valuations then whenever
they can profit from lying they are
going to lie
but is it really the case this is when
we have all economics suggest that it's
not necessarily the situation
in a very cool experiment fisher baham
forming asked participants to wear a
six-sided dice in a cup and report the
results
the pair for the participants was
determined as a function of the number
that they reported so the higher the
number the higher the payoff
now only the participants saw the number
that they hold so in principle they
could all support six and collect the
maximum payoff
what's nice about this experiment is
that even though we cannot tell if a
certain individual lied or not on the
aggregate we can't tell how much the
distribution of reported values is
different than the distributions of
values we expect to get from a fair diet
this experiment was done many many times
different populations different
obviation and in 2019 abell fl published
a meta-analysis including nike papers
and there is the foreign conclusion
participants only collect about 25 of
the potential gains from lying so they
don't say 6 all the time
the following graph is taken from a
website accompanying this method and all
of this and this includes all data from
experiments that were learned in israel
so different colors correspond to
different experiments
on the x-axis we have the value reported
on the y-axis the percentage of people
reporting it
and the dash line is the line of one
over six so what we expect to see if
people report truthfully
and it's pretty clear here that one and
two are underreported while four five
and six are overreported and especially
five is overreported so people do not
lie to the full extent
a couple of explanations that could
explain this phenomena first that there
is some cognitive cost for lying
and second this idea of social identity
so this means that we care about our
perception by others even strangers and
by our own self-perception
and to keep our social identity in line
with our moral standards then we will
try to refrain from lying as much as
possible
another experiment about lying which is
more related to the setting we are
interested in was run by origins in o5
in this experiment there are two
participants one plays the role of the
sender and the other plays the role of
the receiver
now the receiver needs to choose one of
two alternatives either a or b
and only the sender knows the payoff for
which alternative so for example here
for alternative a the sender will get 5
and receiver will get 6 and for
alternative b sander will get 6 and
receiver will get 5.
now based on this information the sender
chooses which message to send
so it can she can either choose to send
a message option b will earn you more
money than option a or the opposite
message
and now the receiver makes it choice and
the powerfully realized according to the
chosen alternative
now eighty percent of the sellers
actually believe that the
recommendations will be followed
in all treatments the option that gives
more money to the receiver is option a
so when the seller recommends option a
this is turning the truth and when the
center commands option b this is lying
in this experiment they did three
treatments so here are a pair for the
different alternatives in the three
treatments
in the first alternative which is the
one we just considered then 36 percent
of defenders lied so they recommended
option b and this is a fairly symmetric
treatment in which there's not too much
to gain by lying
the second treatment only 17 percent
light so now again the sender has
relatively uh
it's not not so much to gain by lying
but the receiver can lose a lot so just
17 light
and in the last alternative when there
is a lot to gain from lying
52 percent lied
and what we conclude for this
that when the benefit from lying is
smaller than the receiver's loss then
sandals tend to lie less
from the experiments we've presented and
other related experiments we can
conclude two behavioral assumptions
first of all individuals have a
preference for tool styling
we can see this in the first experiment
where people do not lie to the full
possible extent
second individuals care about the
damages to adults so in the second
experiment when the damage to others
was high people refrain much more from
lying
in this paper we refer to people obeying
these two assumptions as small bidders
and define mechanisms in which they will
report the two valuations
the rationale here is that a player will
only lie if his profit from lying is
larger than alpha times the sum of
losses of the other players and alpha
here is a parameter between 0 and 1
capturing the extent of say morality of
the bidder
let me tell you about our mechanism a
bit more formally
so the setting we consider is a single
item there is one item that we need to
allocate to one of the players or we
could choose not to allocate it at all
we consider deterministic mechanisms
that are both individually rational so
the payoff of the bidders has to be
non-negative
and no positive transfers the mechanisms
cannot pay the bidders
now formally a mechanism is a pill of f
and allocation function gets the player
value for the items and returns the
identity of the player that the item
will be allocated or we can choose not
to allocate the item at all and a
payment function
determines each player the payment and
each
so a mechanism is alpha mobile if in
every instance v1 through v1
the and we want for vn for every player
i and vi such that player i can in cases
profit by lying so we're poking at
different value v prime i
his profit from lying has to be at most
alpha times the sum of forces of the
others from the lie
so let me walk you through the notation
here
this is the profit of player i
that its true value is v i for reporting
a different volume v prime i
so this difference is the profit from
line
and we want this to be
less than alpha times
the losses of the other players
a couple of things to note about our
mechanisms
so first a total mechanism is zero model
so if you put 0 here this would mean
that the profit from any lie has to be
less than or equal to zero so the player
cannot profit from lying
second the assumption for preference for
tooth turning appears here in the the
bidders measure gains and losses with
with respect to tool styling which is
considered the default option the
default options here
it is important to know that our bidders
are not altruistic they do care about
maximizing their own payoff
only when the bidders need to decide
whether to lie or not in order to
increase their payoff they compare the
benefit from lying versus the damages
that they will inflict upon others
this behavioral assumption fits better
situations in which the beatles know
each other
think for example about an academic
department that need to decide who will
get some expensive piece of equipment so
for example a microscope
then probably people will have harder
time lying and saying that they have a
high value for this equipment when they
know that other people need them more
than they do
i want to demonstrate how moral
mechanisms work using two examples
first we will see that small mechanisms
can be used to implement the same
allocation function as sort of
mechanisms but with different payment
functions
so here we consider the natural
mechanism that allocates the item to the
player with the highest value
and a tossing mechanism can only
implement this allocation function by
charging the highest value below the
critical price which is the second
highest value
small mechanisms on the other hand have
much more flexibility and we can see
that a mole mechanism can for example
charge the highest player the highest
value player half of the second highest
value
so we will show that this mechanism is
one mole
so let me just remind you what we need
to show for one more mechanism we need
to show that the profit of each player
player for line if this is positive
is at most the sum of losses of the
other players from the line
okay
so let's use vk to denote the value of
the player with the maximum value and vj
you know the player the value of the
player with the second highest value
it is easy to see that player k can not
lie to you in case it's profit since the
value that it reports doesn't affect his
profit and he is already already winning
a player that can affect his profit is
some player i that may be able to
increase his profit by reporting vk plus
epsilon by doing so this player will
become the highest value player
okay now let's see if in a more
mechanism the player i could do this
so what we require is that the profit of
player i
formed a slide which is this okay so if
uh player i would report vk plus one you
will get the item for a value of the i
and the second highest value will be vk
so this would be this payment and
require this to be less than equal than
the profit that player k had for getting
the item which is v k minus v j over two
and this inequality indeed holds since
vk is the highest value
so this mechanism is one more mechanism
the second example we will see
demonstrates that more mechanisms can
implement a location functions that
cannot be implemented by tossing
mechanisms
in particular we observe that the
allocation function of a moral mechanism
doesn't have to be monotone
recall that the monotone location
function is one in which if player i won
the item when reporting vi he will also
win it by reporting any value greater
than the i
and the famous characterization tells us
that when the when we allocate a single
item
then we can only implement monotone
location functions by a useful mechanism
okay so what we will see now is a
non-monotone allocation function that
can be implemented by a one mole
mechanism
so the allocation function is given by
the following picture
so here this is the value of player one
and these are the values of player two
the gain area
the sorry the gray areas are areas in
which we don't allocate the item at all
so
when
v q is less than 1 10 and v 1 is less
than 1 we don't allocate the item at all
blue area we allocate the item to player
1
and in this case we charge player one
one
and then we allocate the item to player
two and charge zero so we allocate the
item to player two only in the case that
v one equals 11 over 10.
now this is obviously a disallocation
function is obviously not monotone since
if we are here
so if we are here yeah and player 1
increases his value to 11 over 10 then
suddenly he doesn't get the item anymore
okay so let's see how we can why this
mechanism is one model
first of all if we are in the gray area
or blue area
then it's relatively easy to see that
player 1 cannot gain
anything by lying so if we are in the
blue area then player 1 is already
getting the item and
his price is 1 so misreporting its value
wouldn't change that
if we are in the gay area
then
player one he could misreport his value
for something greater than one but then
since the payment is one his payoff
would be negative
the more interesting part is here when
player 2 is allocated so v1 equals 11
over 10.
we distinguish between two cases so
either v2 is less than 110 so we are
here
and in this case
uh
player 1 doesn't want to misreport its
value since by doing so it will only get
the item to be not allocated to anyone
at all so it doesn't gain anything from
that
if we are in this area then this is
slightly more complicated
and now we need to compare the profits
of player 1 for misreporting so
getting to this region versus the loss
of player two
so if player one will misreport its
value his profit will be
one over tens okay so his value for the
item will be 11 over 10 and uh the
payment is one so this is his profit
this was his profit for telling the
truth and we require this to be less
than v2 minus zero now since we're in
the region where v2 is greater than one
vertex then this inequality indeed holds
and a player that is one mole wouldn't
misreport his value in this case
so the mechanism we just presented in
which the location function is not
monotone is a one mole mechanism
the examples just seen demonstrates that
wall mechanisms extend both the set of
better allocation and dependent
functions supporting them
so my question is you are an engineer
that only cares about maximizing its own
revenue can take advantage of the
morality of the bidders in order to
increase its revenue
and the answer is that it depends
let's first see if the auctioneer can
increase its revenue by using a
different payment function for an
allocation function that is also
implementable by a total mechanism
the following proposition tells us that
it's not the case
so consider a total mechanism m and an
alpha mole mechanism and prime both
implementing the same function f
then we claim that p prime the price for
the uh alpha mobile mechanism is at most
p the price the payment for the total
mechanism
and let me give you the gist of the
proof
so first of all we observe that every
alpha moral mechanism is payment
independent
this means that the price of the winning
player doesn't depend on its value
now let's assume towards contradiction
that uh the price that
player i pays in the alpha model
mechanism is greater than the price it
pays in the total mechanism and this is
the price that player i pays when he
wins
now uh in the total mechanism we know
that the price that the player pays is
its critical value
and in the truthful mechanism we also
know that we can only implement
monotone functions
so this means that player i would win
the item in all of this region
now
since both mechanisms implement the same
function this means that if player i's
value is someplace here then in the
alpha model mechanism he will win the
atom but it's going to pay something
much greater than his value so his
payoff would be negative in
contradiction to the fact that the
mechanism should be individually
rational
so we conclude that the auctioneer can
not increase its revenue by implementing
a function but also implementable by a
total mechanism
this implies that the only possible
benefit of small mechanisms in terms of
revenue is when implementing new
allocation functions
recall that when considering the
question of revenue maximization we
assume that the values of the bidders
don't form distributions that are known
to the auctioneer
our results demonstrate that when the
player's values are on iid the
auctioneer cannot exploit the beta's
morality
however when evaluations are drawn from
a quality distribution there are cases
in which your canadian can exploit the
morality of the bidders to increase its
revenue
more formally
for independent valuations we show that
when the test valuations are drawn iad
from start distribution f i will tell
you what we mean by standard in the next
slide then for any alpha mole mechanism
m there exists a truthful mechanism and
prime that extract at least as much
revenue
for quantity distributions we observe
that the existing two-player quality
distribution for which an alpha model
mechanism can extract a higher revenue
than any transfer mechanism
i will prove that when the various
valuations are on iid the revenue of
more mechanism cannot be higher than the
revenue of a total mechanism holds when
the distributions are standard
standard distributions include uniform
distributions and exponential
distributions
formally these are distributions such
that for every value vj greater than vi
in the support we have that fvj is at
least fvi over 1 plus fvi
now a natural approach for proving such
a theorem would be building on milestone
characterization of optimal auctions
milestone characterized the payment
function in terms of the allocation
function given the characterization
myosin proof completely ignores the
payment function and continues to find
the allocation function that maximizes
the revenue
this approaching healthy fails for all
mechanisms since we observed that the
allocation function of one wall
mechanism is almost unconstrained
that we need to develop all the
machinery required for providing the
theorem from scratch which makes our
proof quite complex
our proof techniques provide an
alternative proof to milestone
characterization of optimal auctions
when the values are drawn from
independent regular distributions so we
showed that the mechanism has to be
sacrificed auction with virtual
evaluations and reserve price
let me summarize our work joins the
going literature and go to game theory
incorporating behavioral assumptions
into well-studied setting
here we develop and analyze mechanisms
for more beetles
our main result is a constructive proof
showing that for standard distributions
and values stone iid
more mechanisms cannot extract more
revenue than trustful ones
what's nice about our proof is that as a
byproduct we obtain an alternative proof
for myosin characterization
one that gradually exposes the mechanism
for quadratic distributions we showed
small mechanisms sometimes do extract
more revenue and may extract up to twice
the revenue of truthful ones
let me mention some open questions
so first of all it will be great to try
to apply our techniques together
characterization of twosome mechanisms
beyond regular distributions
also here focused on the setting of
selling a single item
can we apply more mechanisms to more
general settings like computer options
and more generally i think that studying
other like session to truthfulness for
example as a way to circumvent some of
the impossibility results in the field
could be quite fruitful in level